bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du samsung galaxy s 9
on est à quelques heures du lancement du
s9 quelques bonnes heures du lancement
du s9 mais il va bientôt arriver jusqu'à
présent en exclu pour le prendre en main
au mwc
mais juste avant ce qu'on va faire on va
faire une vidéo pour faire un tour des
tendances des rumeurs pour voir vraiment
ce qui va arriver
les fuites eu énormément de fuites on va
regarder tout de suite ensemble le
portrait robot de galaxy s note et vous
allez dire ce que vous en pensez
on y va maintenant
le samsung galaxy s 9 c'est vraiment un
smartphone qui fait énormément parler
lui il n'est pas arrivé sur le marché
que déjà fait couler beaucoup d'encre
alors c'est vrai que ça n'a pas l'air
d'être vraiment super parce que sans
papiers en tous cas de ce qu'on en
ressent de ce qu'on pressent et de ce
qui fit attentats et de ce qui fit à
droite à gauche par dont il ya vraiment
l'air d'être un smartphone qui est super
intéressant surtout du côté de la photo
et de la vidéo
d'ailleurs si vous suivez samsung sur
youtube et sur les réseaux sociaux vous
aura pas échappé leur corps et leur
slogan pour ce nouveau galaxy s 9 et s9
plus l'appareil photo réinventer la très
clairement cette année ça ne saoule
s'adresse plus que jamais aux créateurs
de contenu ils ont vraiment compris
qu'aujourd'hui ce que les gens utilisent
le plus sur un smartphone à part
effectivement téléphoner et les
applications dans les applications jeux
mais les mails tous à tous packaging au
delà de ça ce qu'on utilise le plus ce
sont nos photos nos vidéos pour partager
sur les réseaux sociaux et pour se créer
des souvenirs donc justement on devrait
avoir un smartphone en 2018
made in samsung le haut de gamme un
produit super intéressant d'ailleurs il
ya le à lui qui est sorti ya pas
longtemps si vous n'avez pas suivi
vous êtes plusieurs vidéos de test je
vous invite à aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil c'est vrai que ça 8 est vraiment
très très bien dans le milieu de gamme
et là les régionales dans les hauts de
gamme
prenez vraiment de déchirer alors il ya
des fuites de tous les côtés il ya une
fuite par un utilisateur de ré dit qu' a
priori aurait pu prendre en main pendant
plusieurs minutes il a voulu partager
son expérience il a permis à des
utilisateurs lui poser des questions et
puis effectivement de donner son
ressenti par rapport à ce produit la
chose qui l'a vraiment bluffé c'est
l'amélioration significative des haut
parleurs stéréo
a priori ce serait des haut-parleurs
signé à kg sur ce galaxy s 9 et la
qualité sonore serait vraiment au rendez
vous autre chose qui l'a remarqué c'est
effectivement toujours la présence du
port jack bio sa j'adore
l'appareil photo toujours au centre avec
le capteur d'empreintes digitales
dessous comment on peut retrouver sur
l'a8 selon lui c'est vraiment pas de
regret parce que le doivent a toujours
flirté un petit peu avec l'appareil
photo et là je suis entièrement d'accord
parce que c'est en tout cas le point de
regret que j'ai également sur le a8 et
je pense que c'est ce qu'on va voir
aussi sur le s9 donc ça s'est encore pas
idéal mais y auraient leur faut gagner
pas d'amélioration pour le modèle delà
des prochaines
mais c'est vrai que là il aurait pu
faire encore un peu mieux j'imagine que
clairement
ils nous font une seule et même des
coupes pour intégrer un capteur photo
est un acteur d'empreintes digitales
dessous c'est juste une question de
coûts parce que si vous allez découper à
plusieurs endroits ça va vous coûter
forcément plus cher à la conception
à mon avis le problème ici tu de ce
point de vue là le bouton x by serait
également toujours de la partie alors
bigbee c'est vrai qu'en france n'est pas
particulièrement utilisé c'est dommage
parce que l'intelligence artificielle
quelque chose qui se développe
énormément
que ce soit du côté de google que ce
soit du côté de samsung soit du côté de
apple de huawei c'est quelque chose qui
va développer encore plus cette année
dans les années à venir
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on va suivre
aussi énormément mais aussi une fuite la
semaine dernière qui vient du site de
orange roumanie
orange aurait directement publier la
fiche produit d'une samsung galaxy s 9
alors qu'est ce qu'on apprend on apprend
les couleurs déjà noir bleu et violet on
voit aussi un peu la fiche technique de
ce set alors ça je suis un peu plus
dubitatif et autant les couleurs
j'arrive vraiment y croire en temps la
fiche technique qui a été partagée j'y
crois beaucoup moins tout simplement
parce que le processeur annoncé l'exynos
n'est pas albinos qu'on devrait
retrouver dans le prochain et ce 9e nous
annonçant un exil aux fuites 1895 à mon
avis sont implantées par contre
effectivement ce qui est non c'est une
double ouverture au niveau de la caméra
arrière ça ça devait effectivement être
un des points forts de ce nouveau galaxy
s 9 1 points mais là c'est
révolutionnaire sur les appareils photo
dans les smartphones une ouverture
réglable ce qui fait que lorsque vous
auriez une belle luminosité que vous
saurez extérieur vous pourrez vraiment
avoir quelque chose de complètement
optimisé
lorsque vous aurez beaucoup moins de
lumière vous pourriez avoir une
ouverture qui serait beaucoup plus bas
donc permettrait de capter davantage la
lumière l'appareil photo devrait d'une
meilleure qualité en règle générale soit
pour le mode portrait que ce soit pour
tout ce que vous voudrions faire vous
devriez voir quelque chose de vraiment
optimisé il ya aussi eu des fuites sur
le chargeur rapide à induction
on a des photos qui nous permette
effectivement voir à quoi devrait
ressembler ce chargeur rapide mais
également des croquis qui nous
permettent de comprendre un petit peu
comment il fonctionne de l'anticiper
passe quelque chose qui est vraiment
intéressant tout s'y fit paraître
vraiment d'avoir un vrai portrait robot
de ce que devront tête ses galaxy s 9 et
s9 plus la question qu'on est en droit
de se poser maintenant c'est par rapport
à toutes ces infos toutes ces filles
toutes ces rumeurs
est ce que si vous avez
s suit un autre fuite ou un smartphone
récent est ce que vous devez changer
pour aller sur le s9 os9 plus alors pour
moi la réponse est très claire c'est non
on doit changer de smartphone pour aller
vers un smartphone pour deux raisons
principales la première c'est si le
smartphone vous a lâché là effectivement
il ya un moment il faut renouveler et le
deuxième point qui perd importance et si
vous avez un vrai besoin
le problème que rencontre aujourd'hui
c'est que les smartphones est en règle
générale sur la tex en même temps tous
les produits on a toujours des choses
qui sont hyper alléchante qui nous font
vraiment envie et on dit cac
si changer et si je passais de mon
smartphone qui marche encore et qui a
encore de bons résultats à ce tout
nouveau smartphone sauf que ça c'est
cher du point de vue portefeuille
c'est cher du point de vue écologique je
ne suis pas sûr que ce soit vraiment
nécessaire si vous devez changer pour
aller sur le s9 il faut soit que vous
alliez enterrer votre smartphone qu'ils
soient dead six pieds sous terre soit à
ce moment là que vous ayez un réel
besoin notamment en termes de photos et
vidéos maintenant la question c'est si
vous devez changer votre smartphone
pourquoi est ce que cela est neuf serez
séduisant et pourquoi est ce que vous
devriez aller dessus tout va se jouer au
niveau de la photo et la vidéo un
capteur avec une double ouverture c'est
vraiment un truc de dingue qu'on n'a
jamais trouvé
on devrait aller plus loin aussi en
termes de ralentis probablement du 480
images par seconde
effectivement sonic est sorti un produit
à 1000 images par le monde on n'était
pas encore sur les produits samsung a
priori on se fait pas sur un mille
images par seconde
ça ça reste encore à voir 480 images par
seconde ce serait déjà très très bien
c'est par les traits d'avoir des
ralentis extrêmement fluide un truc qui
est vraiment super donc si vous êtes
créateur de contenu soit sûr de la photo
de la vidéo que vous publiez énormément
sera compte instagram sur du snap chatte
même sur youtube
je pense que ce galaxy s 9 peut vraiment
être intéressant pour nous d'ailleurs si
vous aimez regarder le teaser de samsung
sur ce nouveau s 9,6 hors officiel
longtemps les plus de la rumeur il faut
un focus sur la photo sur la vidéo qui
complètement incroyable qu'est ce qu'on
comprend dedans on comprend le côté avec
une ouverture variable dans leur image
quelque chose qui ressort énormément on
comprend effectivement de parler imoges
qu'on devrait avoir l'équivalent des
animaux logique d'apple donc des impôts
dgi
animée ça veut dire une caméra avant qui
va être capable de scanner votre visage
est de reconnaître en temps réel les
déformations de votre visage vos
différents mouvements pour les appliquer
directement sur des impôts dgi donc
l'équivalent chez samsung de la caméra
trop dess de chez apple
donc effectivement beaucoup plus de
fonctionnalités beaucoup plus de
sécurité
aussi en termes de déverrouillage pense
que pour l'instant la reconnaissance
faciale chez samsung
ce n'est pas encore tout à fait ça là
effectivement si on va beaucoup plus
loin avec l'équivalent de la cataracte
roudeix on va avoir des produits encore
plus sécurisé et ça c'est super
intéressant
en plus ce qui pourrait être intéressant
c'est le prix samsung a fait entendre
que lorsque la concurrence innove elle
augmente ses prix eux sur ce produit là
n'augmenteraient pas leur prix au 1er
avoir quelque chose de vraiment bien
placé en termes de tarifs pour moi
j'étais plutôt tendance à penser le
contraire parce que pour moi dès lors
vous avez un produit innovant sa demande
de la recherche et développement se vend
des matériaux plus coûteux et des marges
qui doivent toujours être tiré plutôt
vers le haut voire en tout cas démarche
quand elles n'ont pas sacrifié donc un
produit plus cher
a priori c'est s9 s9 plus devrait bien
placé à voir parce que l'année dernière
le s uite des sorties et 809 euros et le
s suit plus si je vous dis pas de
bêtises c'était 909 euros
on va voir si c'est s9 et s9 plus se
maintienne ou alors coûte un peu moins
cher
alors maintenant pourquoi ne pas
l'acheter pourquoi ne pas aller sur cs
9,9 plus et comme je vous le dis tout
simplement déjà si vous avez un
smartphone qui pour l'instant fait
encore la faire par rapport à vos
besoins actuels tant que votre
smartphone marche ça ne sert strictement
à rien de changer acheter pour acheter
c'est dommage après c'est à vous de voir
effectivement mais vous risquez de jeter
de l'argent dans l'air ça coûte quand
même relativement cher et d'ailleurs
vous avez un produit qui marche
je vois pas tout de suite l'intérêt si
vous n'avez pas besoin de photos et de
vidéos se s 9,9 plus sont pas
nécessairement fait pour vous c'est
effectivement des produits qui vont être
puissant va y avoir pas mal de choses à
faire je pense du côté des emoji mais si
c'est quelque chose qui ne vous
intéressent pas si la photo la vidéo
pour vous c'est plutôt secondaire vous
voulez des souvenirs bonne qualité je
suis pas sûr que ce soit un produit sur
lequel il faut y aller si vous voulez
pas de quatre cas par exemple le a8 fera
très bien à faire le one + 5 t pour
aussi très bien faire la faire le honor
view 10 pourrait très bien marché aussi
des produits chinois huawei ils sont
beaucoup moins chers qui pourront vous
satisfaire voilà donc ça c'est
effectivement tout ces paramètres à
prendre en considération pour moi c'est
samsung galaxy s 9 et s9 plus s'adresse
vrai
aux créateurs de contenu aux amoureux de
la photo et de la vidéo qui veulent
aller toujours plus loin qu'ils veulent
des produits technologiques qui leur
permettent de mettre en avant leur
créativité et d'aller toujours plus loin
au niveau de leur rendu pour un rendu de
qualité de surprendre et d'innover en
permanence en termes de création c'est
vraiment le fil conducteur de 500
aujourd'hui sur ces produits là et si
vous êtes dans cette mouvance
il faut y aller sinon je suis patient
soit très intéressant pour vous en gros
si on résume bien les esses 9,9 plus
voudriez avoir des photos et de la vidéo
qui serait complètement dingue une
autonomie incroyable de la sécurité
renforcée des mgi animer un écran bord à
bord d'une qualité incroyable un
stockage qui pourra aller jusqu'à 512
gigaoctets sur le papier c'est s9 et s9
plus risque vraiment de mettre la barre
encore très haut est vraiment continuer
cette guerre entre apple et samsung
entre l'iphone 10 et entre eux c'est
galaxy s 9 et à ce même plus dit -
d'ailleurs vous ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est s9 s9
plus vous êtes vraiment très bon cru
est-ce que vous pensez que ça va juste
être une évolution du spt suit plus
est-ce que vous l'attendez vraiment avec
impatience lorsque vous avez pas dresser
sur votre faim dites moi tout ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire je vous
avais bien sûr à vous abonner parce que
d'ici quelques jours je vais les prendre
dans mes mains dès sa sortie dès son
annonce donc rester connecté
abonnez-vous va y avoir toujours plus de
contenu pour parler d'eux tech de
smartphones de votre vie numérique
d'énormément sujet hyper intéressant
donc je vous invite à rester connectés
je vous invite bien évidemment comme
d'hab année c'est des jolies pouces
d'ici là resté sage je vous embrasse
portez vous bien
à bientôt chan
ma